[Musique]
on est où là alors j'imagine chez vous
alors c'est dans ma chambre
bonjour nicolas bouzou bonjour la crise
renforce les croyances des uns et des
autres écologistes populiste étatiste
plus qu'elle ne les ébranle c'est ce que
vous écrivez dans un petit texte écrit
il y a quelques jours inventons la
mondialisation aux édition de
l'observatoire vous même vous ne savez
pas à la règle vous êtes un libéral
revendiquez vous mettez la liberté au
dessus de tout et pourtant dans ce texte
vous nous invitez à penser contre nous
mêmes alors en quoi cette crise vous
êtes branle vous l'économiste mais si je
prends la question de la mondialisation
il ya très clairement un facteur que
j'avais sous-estimé c'est la dépendance
d'un certain nombre de pays à des
sources unique d'approvisionnement le
fait alors je suis sans doute un peu
dogmatique évidemment comme tout le
monde enfin le fait que 90% de la
pénicilline qui est là des antibiotiques
les plus utilisés dans le monde soit
fabriqué en chine ait quelque chose qui
me pose problème et ça c'est quelque
chose donc je fais mon mea culpa je fais
mon analyse intellectuelle c'est quelque
chose que j'avais vu mais si vous voulez
qu'il n'avait pas semblé comme étant
l'un des principaux dangers qui pouvait
menacer notre économie et notre
indépendance et donc je fais mon mea
culpa aussi en termes de propositions
c'est à dire que j'essaie de réfléchir à
la façon dont on peut retrouver de
retrouver de la dépendance mais c'est
vrai qu'il ya des choses que j'avais que
j'avais sous-estimé et des
dysfonctionnements de la mondialisation
économique et financière parce que
j'insiste là dessus mais la
mondialisation pour moi c'est quelque
chose de beaucoup plus large et qui va
très au delà de l'économie mais il ya
des dysfonctionnements de la
mondialisation économique et financière
que nous devons corriger alors justement
va y venir à ces dysfonctionnements à
cette question de notre interdépendance
sur les productions d'un même bien entre
les états mais avant cela ce qui frappe
à vous dire c'est que vous ne blâmez pas
mondialisation et l'économie mondiales
de marché vous dit même que ça n'est pas
qu'un phénomène économique
ah bon bien sûr non la mondialisation
c'est avant tout un phénomène culturel
est un phénomène civilisationnel alors
déjà la mondialisation c'est quelque
chose qui d'une certaine façon a
toujours existé dans la mesure où pour
les humains ont toujours voulu partir
ils ont toujours voulu aller ailleurs
savez ça fait deux cent mille ans
qu'homo sapiens a quitté l'afrique on
sait pas d'ailleurs encore très
exactement pourquoi il est parti mais il
est peut-être parti parce qu'il y était
obligé mais il est peut-être parti aussi
pour voir autre chance pour découvrir
autre chose et donc on a eu des grandes
vagues de mondialisation la grèce
antique un bien évidemment le siècle de
périclès mais aussi la renaissance le
19e siècle donc voyez que la
mondialisation c'est quelque chose qui
vient du fond de notre histoire et en
effet c'est avant tout un phénomène
anthropologique est un phénomène
culturel il ya une bibliothèque derrière
moi il y en a une derrière vous aussi et
bien dans cette bibliothèque
il y a des des auteurs qui sont des
auteurs absolument universal il ya des
auteurs qui
pensent très au delà des frontières le
prix nobel de littérature par exemple
mario vargas llosa qui est pour moi l'un
des plus grands écrivains contemporains
mêmes et même au delà c'est quelqu'un
qui est né au pérou qui a la double
nationalité péruvienne et espagnole qui
passe sa vie à voyager et qui a conservé
une identité péruvienne mais qui en même
temps est un universaliste qui n'est pas
dans le folklore mais qui nous émeut qui
nous passionne vous et moi alors même
que nous n'avons pas de la tâche avec le
pérou donc la mondialisation c'est aussi
quelque chose comme ça sans
mondialisation culturelle il n'y aurait
pas de vargas llosa lloret pas de
cervantès serait pas de miles davis
serait pas de david bowie c'est à dire
des gens qui vraiment ont utilisé des
influences qui vont très au delà de
leurs frontières quand est-ce que
exactement la mondialisation nous a fait
basculer de l'ouverture des échanges de
marchandises à l'ensemble de la planète
à l'ensemble des pays à cette
interdépendance des états pour produire
un même bien le les fon portable par
exemple
c'est très récent ça remonte au fond aux
années 90 c'est à dire au moment à
partir duquel les technologies de
l'information et de la communication et
la baisse de coûts des transports
aériens a permis de passer à une
deuxième phase de la mondialisation qui
est celle de la mondialisation des
chaînes de valeur ce que je veux dire
par là c'est que jusqu alors il y avait
bien sûr une mondialisation des échanges
de biens et services mais depuis les
années 90 il ya sept c'est cette
globalisation de l'organisation des
entreprises et c'est à partir de là où
en effet alors pour prendre un exemple
caricatural qui est souvent primé un
smartphone inclut des composants qui
sont produits dans le monde entier et si
un seul de ces composants manque et bien
le smartphone ne peut pas être produit
et donc c'est à partir de là où on a une
dépendance des produits de grande
consommation des produits que nous
consommons extrême à un tout petit
maillon de la chaîne de valeur qui peut
être située dans un pays qui pour des
raisons x ou y ne peut plus produire à
une certaine période du temps alors en
même temps c'est très efficace on le
voit bien parce qu'on a accès à beaucoup
de bien de consommation de très grande
qualité et à des prix qui sont des prix
modiques alors c'est pas le cas de tous
les smartphones mais c'est le cas des
produits manufacturés en règle générale
donc c'est formidablement efficace
économiquement mais en même temps ça
génère des risques qui sont pour
l'essentiel des risques de dépendances
mais sur certains biens très particulier
comme celui de la santé
quand sanofi décide de faire produire
non pas 20 30 40 mais 100% du
paracétamol en chine ou en inde comment
expliquer qu'on ait laissé faire ça et
bien parce que nous avions sous-estimé
ce phénomène de perte d'indépendance
parce que sans doute nous n'imaginions
pas que une telle crise puisse nous
tomber dessus alors quand je dis que
nous l'imaginions pas en réalité on
savait très bien qu'il y avait des
épidémies on savait très bien que dans
un monde globalisé et un monde de
métropolisation parce que la
mondialisation contemporaine elle est
aussi
caractérisée par des concentrations
extrêmement forte de population on
savait bien que dans ce monde là il y
avait un risque d'épidémie mais c'est
quelque chose qui est laid ce qu'est un
peu qui restait un peu théorique dans
nos dans mon esprit on pensait
d'ailleurs en matière de santé qu'on
avait quitté au fond le risque
épidémique pour rentrer dans un nouvel
âge de la santé qui était celui des des
maladies chroniques ce qu'on appelle en
france des affections longue durée les
les cancers le diabète les maladies
neurodégénératives
on se rend compte que c'est pas tout à
fait le cas et donc je pense que par
rapport à ça il faut pas dire c'est là
c'est la modélisation qui coupable c'est
la fin de la mondialisation c'est pas ça
il faut aller au delà de ça et se dire
qu'est ce qu'on fait pour améliorer la
mondialisation alors sur le sujet dont
vous parlez moi je propose quelque chose
qui est simple je propose que nous
définissions ce que l'on pourrait
appeler des secteurs essentiels
il existe déjà dans la loi des secteurs
stratégiques sont protégés
d'investissements étrangers on peut
définir des secteurs essentiels pour
lesquels ont défini un quota minimum
d'introduction sur le territoire
français sur le territoire européen et
donc votre compréhension entre les
tenants oui c'est ma proposition très
hauts des bas inscrire dans la loi des
secteurs d'activité essentiels comme la
pharmacie l'agroalimentaire qui va
définir ces secteurs et comment au fond
l'état peut obliger les entreprises à
relocaliser à produire en france
certains biens essentiels à la nation
est ce que l'état peut faire ça est ce
qu'il vient faire ça bien sûr je pense
mais je pense qu'il faut le faire
intelligemment c'est à dire que il faut
pas se dire que tous les secteurs sont
des secteurs qui doivent absolument
produire sur le sol français là les
vêtements que nous portons sont en très
grande partie produit sur notre sol et
ça ne me pose évidemment pas de
difficultés la mondialisation c'est
c'est le t-shirt à aller à 5 euros 10
euros maximum ça vous voulez que ça
continue au fond il faut il faut
continuer à essayer chercher le plus bas
coût pour le consommateur en produisant
le plus loin possible si nécessaire dans
certains secteurs comme le t-shirt
s'avoue et et revenir à des médicaments
produits en france non pas du tout parce
que c'est pas la peine si on peut éviter
d'acheter des t-shirts à 2 ou 3 euros
c'est mieux d'éviter de le faire en même
temps c'est à dire il ya aussi des temps
dans notre pays qui ont des difficultés
financières qui sont en vente souffrance
sociale et je ne veux pas leur faire
porter le poids de la culpabilité bien
évidemment donc eux doivent pouvoir
acheter des t-shirts qui ne sont pas
cher ça m'est arrivé par le passé ça
n'arrivera peut-être à l'avenir donc je
pense qu'il faut avoir ça en tête mais
pense que bien évidemment c'est mieux
d'acheter de la qualité en tout
simplement vous avez aussi des produits
de très haute qualité qui sont impliqués
dans des pays émergents et notamment des
pays du sud est asiatique dont condé
mondiale est ce pas dans tous les
secteurs dans un premier temps non mais
même dans un deuxième temps je suis tout
à fait opposé je suis opposé à l'idée de
démondialisation
je pense en revanche mais mon idée
d'ailleurs été moins
économique que politique parce que les
relocalisations dont on parle dans
l'agroalimentaire ou dans la pharmacie
ça ne va pas créer énormément d'emplois
on va pas récréer d'énormément d'emploi
par les relocalisations va créer
énormément d'emplois par une
industrialisation du futur par un grand
plan d'industrialisation de l'europe la
question des relocalisations pour moi
c'est une question de souveraineté est
question donc donc politique et oui bien
évidemment je reviens à votre question
originale c'est tout à fait possible
quels sont les secteurs incriminés moi
j'en ai cité 2 mais il y en a peut-être
d'autres alors faut pas non plus en
faire trop parce que on va pas tout
produire sur le sol français c'est là où
il faut pas pardonnez moi l'expression
n'est pas très belle mais il faut pas
jeter le bébé avec l'eau du bain parce
que tout produire en france ça voudrait
dire que évidemment on produits à des
coûts de production qui sont beaucoup
plus élevés qu'aujourd'hui ça voudrait
dire que les consommer tout ça s'est
payé par le consommateur en bout de
chaîne ça voudrait dire que les
consommateurs doivent accepter de payer
l'énergie steiner ça n'est que les
français sont prêts ils sont prêts à
payer plus cher je pense d'abord à
l'alimentation à la chaîne
agroalimentaire est ce que vous pensez
qu'on ait un point de bascule ou même
pour les ménages les plus modestes
parfois un peu plus cher peut être une
motivation pour manger local et pour au
fond
réaffirmé les chaînes de valeur et se
déprendre de
la dépendance à des pays où on produit à
très bas coût
peut-être mais très honnêtement j'en
suis pas certain et malheureusement je
sais aussi que nous allons au devant de
gros problèmes économiques et de
problèmes sociaux et donc cette idée
selon laquelle tout le monde pourrait
accepter de payer une alimentation plus
cher je pense que c'est une idée à
laquelle il faut faire attention ce quoi
que il faut en quelque sorte qu'on soit
un peu plus ambitieux c'est à dire que
peut-être qu'on va être obligé de
produire plus cher mais je crois qu'on
doit produire autrement en maintenant
une autre qualité et on peut le faire
parce qu'on a les technologies
aujourd'hui qui permettent de faire ça
c'est ce que l'on appelle pardonnez-moi
de jargonner un tout petit peu mais les
usines 4.0 c'est à dire des usines dans
laquelle on a beaucoup de numérique on a
beaucoup de robots il ya malheureusement
trop peu de repos en france il faut plus
de robots de l'intelligence artificielle
des imprimantes 3d à ce qu'on appelle la
fabrication additive parce que tout ça
ça permet d'industrialiser avec un coût
d'investissement importants au départ
mais qu'on peut assez facilement amortir
dans le temps donc on a vraiment un coup
à jouer pour faire 2-2 la qualité à des
prix que l'on arrivera à maîtriser mais
ça prendra du temps sa demande a en même
temps sa voix des années des années bien
évidemment c'est pas quelque chose qu'on
va faire en deux ou trois mois mais je
n'aurais pas éteint il ya vraiment pour
moi 2-2 sujet il ya le sujet des
relocalisations dans les secteurs dans
lesquels nous devons protéger notre
indépendance et il ya le sujet
passionnant de l'industrialisation de de
l'europe je pense que c'est un sujet à
traiter au niveau européen mais reste
que dans ces économies là les économies
de la troisième révolution industrielle
les économies du futur de la
robotisation de l'intelligence
artificielle l'europe elle a plutôt une
longueur de retard par rapport à la
chine et aux états unis
si c'est cette économie là qui va au
fond
enrichir la reprise de l'activité après
la crise et nous offrir des perspectives
c'est pas très réjouissant pour les
européens que nous sommes est ce que
c'est pas perdu d'avancé c'est pas
réjouissant mais justement il faut faire
en sorte que ça devienne réjouissant
c'est à dire qu'il faut qu'on
réfléchisse à la façon dont on peut
rattraper trop tard mais il nous manque
des choses on a un marché européen qui
n'est pas assez homogène on n'a pas nous
manque une grande bourse européenne
avant la sdac pour que nos entreprises
puissent lever des capitaux au manque
aussi d'une prise de décision au niveau
européen d'une politique industrielle
qui fasse que on encourage de ces
nouveaux acteurs au lieu de leur mettre
des bâtons dans les roues mais ça faut
le faire là maintenant merci nous avons
accordé cet entretien nicolas bouzou et
à bientôt à bientôt
[Musique]